good morning Hank it's Monday it's pizza
miss I only get to say good morning Hank
it's Monday once a year on hikes a mess
hi how are you I'm good beats misses a
two-week period where Hank and I make
videos back and forth to each other
every week date to celebrate Brotherhood
and affection and pizza and e-commerce
hey Hank
uh-huh do you know why I haven't shaved
since the book came out is it a luck
thing
nope AFC Wimbledon no that's the
business I know it is great thank you
for noticing all right we're in the
dftba.com warehouse which means that we
are we've the pizza miss stuff right now
that is on sale only for the next two
weeks Hank let's do a pizza miss
unboxing video it's a haul the great
thing about this also is that it serves
as a theft deterrent and because nobody
wants to rob this car the pizza miss hat
it's really good it's sound like subtle
we're not trying to throw it in your
face does it look good with the mustache
and pizza boys shirts all right here we
have a bunch of different designers do a
pizza most design for us so their take
on pizza John this is Lily machinist
chibi John Palmer did this one it's
amazing oh my goodness and then we've
got this one drippy pizza face - were Oh
oh boy thank you so hers a big deal okay
I think this is the best year Pizza miss
ever I know
these are Joey choose all these get
availability hp.com only for two weeks
managing this project is one of my
favorite things to do every year I just
get to tell designers to be weird and
then the weirder it is the happier I am
yeah you like this one Oh what do you
think did this one hmm I don't know who
thought cafe I also feel like this is a
gift that you give to me every year
it's the weirdest time of the year
daily videos for no reason other than to
honk we heard Pizza John March but all
year round and I'm very grateful for
this oh my god it's my face that's a
piece of pizza it's so men up I love
that everybody's worked the moustache in
one way or another hey it's almost like
my mustache is actually awesome and
people like it everyone leave will have
a pole on the side of the video yeah
phallus if you like John's mustache and
want it to stay I would say tell us that
you like John's mustache and want it to
whether that pajama top achieve at all
it's so comfy see doesn't that look
great I feel ready for professionally
styled but actually I have to say in
fact look good thank you
great I have been working out as you
know that is incredibly comfortable oh
it's like a warm hug and then there's
this amazing sweatshirt which was
designed by Beth Radloff it's so cozy my
kids are finally gonna think I'm cool
we're just at the cusp of the beginning
of the fidgets spinner fan to would
write great thinking this is a
high-quality fidget spinner actually so
those little faces on there this is my
last Pizza John surprise of 2017 I just
want to say thanks to you and everybody
at the espn.com for making this already
a great piece of miss it's a pizza John
shot glass for your real pizza parties
or when you go Pizza hearty it's great I
mean it's definitely a pizza John shot
glass and this marks the first time I
don't know nerdfighter is getting older
I guess it's okay yeah you can drink
whatever you want out of it that's true
it's a shot of Ovaltine there's also a
lapel pin pictured because we don't have
it in stock yet and John and I just
spent a lot of time signing these and
then John still coca-cola on a bunch of
them yep sorry about that those will be
discounted but all the profits from the
posters will go to the National Alliance
for mental illness Nami if you come up
with a pizza John cocktail for us virgin
and alcoholic put in the comments we're
gonna select a top one that we like the
most and we're gonna send all the pizza
and stuff to you Hank and I will drink
all of the suggestions and then we will
make a decision terrible improvisation
think I'll continue to see you right now
but also I'll see you tomorrow okay and
the next day